what do you make of the report titled
preliminary assessment
unidentified aerial phenomena that was
released by the office of the director
of national intelligence in june 2021 so
this is what's like um
okay we're going to step back and we're
going to like what
where do we stand and where do we hope
the future is what do you make of that
report is it hopeful is it i see it as
very helpful very hopeful i think the
adults are finally stepping up in and
being in charge
right in a good sense of adult
what's that in the good sense and the
good sense of adult
um
because childlike curiosity is pretty
powerful thing that's true yeah i i it's
but it's also i think the people who
were worried that the populace at large
might run screaming into the streets and
riot
uh you know have
you know they basically the empiric
evidence is they're wrong
you know this
these videos and all these things have
been out for now what five years
most people don't even know about it
right so as as as hyped as it's been and
all over the newspapers that it's been
and etc you know even tucker carlson has
talked about it many times on his news
program
um joe rogan has a lot of people don't
know about it so i think people if it's
not affecting their day-to-day life
they're going on with their day-to-day
life
so but that said
i think it was an important
sea change
in the internal discussions going on in
the government because
and the reason being
that
i think this is actually partly true
with the the maturation of human social
technology
it was becoming so obvious that this
stuff was showing up again and again and
again around our ships they just
couldn't keep it quiet anymore right and
so it's like we need to do something
about it and lou elizondo and chris and
others to their great credit
found the right angle
to talk about this it says well okay
let's say it's not
out there
maybe it's the russians the chinese or
somebody else we should know about this
because we damn sure no it's not us
so
that to me
is an important thing to to finally be a
little bit more open about the matter
but
like i often say i'm not looking for
people to give me permission to do
anything i'm just going to do the
analysis myself with what i have avi
loeb has taken the same approach he said
i'm not going to wait for the government
to give me
telescopic information about
technologies or
things that might be even on our own
solar system i'm just going to collect
it myself
and and that's the right way to do it
right don't wait for somebody else to
give it to you
it's also possible to
inspire a large number of people to do a
wider spread data collection yes you
yourself can't
do a large enough data collection that
would if you're talking about anomalous
events right
right you you should be
collecting high resolution data
about everything that's happening on
earth in terms of like at
in terms of the kind of
things that would indicate to you a
strong signal that something weird
happened here and this is why
you know governments can be good at
funding large-scale efforts yes i mean
you know nasa and and so on working with
spacex uh with blue origin
uh
to you know fund
uh capitalistic sort of fun companies
fun company efforts to do huge moonshot
projects
and in the same way do huge moonshot
data collection efforts in terms of ufos
i mean we're not it needs to be like 10x
like one or two orders of magnitude more
funding exactly to do this kind of thing
and i i understand on the flip side of
that if you make it about what are the
russians whether the chinese doing
you make it a question of geopolitics
it gets touchy because now you you're
kind of taken away from the realm of
science
and making it military making it
military some of the greatest this is
what makes me as an engineer
makes me truly sad that some of the
greatest engineering work ever done
is by lockheed martin and we will never
know about it yeah i agree i agree i i
wish
we were it was different but um it's the
world we live in
um you know but related to that uap task
force
announcement that you just said you know
the bill was passed in the department of
defense and now it formally establishes
an office
to
collate that information and also to be
transparent about it
money is now set aside
you